shortly after touching down on the ocean
of storms
a volcanic plane on the near side of the
moon china state television showed
pictures of yet another homegrown
technological breakthrough in space
changi wu or long march 5 is on a
historic mission to bring back
rock and soil samples from the moon the
first such mission in more than 40 years
this movement is the first step it's
steadily landed on the surface
very steady and very good laying a very
important foundation for the next steps
the lander has a number of instruments
to make this happen including a camera
as well as scoop and drill capabilities
next there's the drilling and collecting
of samples on the surface
unfolding the national flag and making
preparations for taking off
if all goes to plan two kilograms of
rock and soil samples will be brought to
earth later this month
with hopes of learning more about the
moon's origins formation and volcanic
activity
but first another historic feat an
unmanned meeting and docking with return
craft in lunar orbit
380 000 kilometers away from earth
although we've done the landing twice
before this mission the lander is
heavier than the jade rabbit rover
so it's harder to control and requires
more precision
that mission last year landed a rover on
the dark side of the moon which has
never been done before
it's still roaming around exploring the
surface and sending back
images like these billions of dollars
are being poured into china's
military-run space program which has
ambitious plans in store
including building a moon base in the
coming years and a space station
with a permanent crew the mission is
expected to wrap up when the spacecraft
returns with its samples
likely to land in inner mongolia later
this month
andrew chappelle al jazeera